foreign
dirt and grime from under your toenails
the types of crowds that I use are
called striped shore crabs and they can
be found right on the shoreline within
the Rocks mostly on the western side of
the United States
they're scavengers so they pretty much
eat anything that they can grab but
their primary diet is algae so the key
to attracting crabs towards your toes is
a lot of observing the crabs that are on
the shoreline so where I live in San
Diego California there's hundreds if not
thousands of these crabs so you stand
there you can watch all over where
they're at and I look for crabs that are
actively like picking algae off the
Rocks because they're showing me that
they're very hungry you gotta stand
there very patiently but if you put your
foot right in there where they're eating
off the Rock 10 20 maybe 30 minutes
later they'll slowly come out and if you
haven't been moving they'll start to uh
try your tahoosa
most of the time I'm out there for hours
at a time it's very uncomfortable but
yes you have to stand completely still
otherwise they will get scared of you
so what the crab is doing is pulling out
a lot of build up from under the toes
the easiest step for them to grab
there's a lot of testing for the crab
it's then you'll see it like pinching at
different things just to see what it
can't actually grab onto because I don't
believe they have very good eyesight so
I don't think it really knows what it's
grabbing at but it's just reaching for
what it can
they taste with their toes so if it's
touching my feet with his toes to like
see what I am then I know it's somewhat
interested but generally you can tell
within a couple of seconds or minutes
that a crab is interested or not
they also can taste up their mouth so
they have unlike us multiple ways of
tasting
I do not know why they find toes
appetizing I've never asked a crab but
they uh they do
so sometimes luckily there's a hangnail
or or a little piece of skin on the edge
and they really like that but they'll
try to go for like the flat surfaces but
it doesn't look like they're grabbing
much because they're not
the feeling I would describe for a crab
pedicure is kind of like a tugging
sensation everybody's feet are different
but for me there's no like pain involved
it's just kind of like a pulling
sensation which I find relaxing weirdly
I don't know
the majority of them are very afraid of
me they are very delicate so if you miss
that or whatnot be a bad day for the
crab so eating human skin I don't have
any proof affects them negatively
because they're scavengers I always come
from a Viewpoint of they eat a lot worse
because they'll literally dead birds
that are crying between rocks which I
think is a lot worse but I am also not a
wildlife biologist so I don't know 100
percent
as far as I know there is no way of
getting sick from the crabs or uh the
crabs getting sick from me there's
potential for there being diseases
within a crowd just like anything else
and so I would never let a crab picket
an open wound I would never let a crab
pick at anything that's Raw on my skin
but other than that I have never had
issues within my entire life
the final results of the pedicure is
generally a lot cleaner under the
toenail and along the sides of the
toenail so any hangnails are usually
gone by the time they're done they will
clean the top of your toenail pretty
good too they just won't clip your
toenails for you and I'm trying to
figure that one out how they can do that
for me too